hey this is pre to
Walker there are a couple of puzzles
that are getting millions and millions
of views on social media and even some
press coverage so let's solve them once
and for
all there is a formidable puzzle that's
literally making the internet go
hysterical right
meow the potential ambiguity did give me
pause but I thought not covering it
would be an even greater
catastrophe let me read the equations
aloud the first equation is cat plus cat
plus cat is equal to 30 the second is
cat plus head plus head is equal to 20
the third equation is cat plus 2 feet
plus 2 feet is equal to 9 and the final
line is the expression to evaluate this
is cat head plus a single foot multipli
by cat is equal to question
mark so what's the
answer I thinkk John for the
suggestion here's another puzzle that's
making the Rounds Around the
Clock some people say this puzzle is a
bit corny and there may be a kernel of
Truth to that so I am all ears for any
suggestions on how to do it but since
the puzzle is out there I decided I may
as well solve it the first equation
reads corn plus corn plus corn is equal
to 75 the second equation is corn plus
popcorn plus popcorn is equal to
65 the third line shows a clock at
2:00 plus popcorn plus corn is equal to
47 the final line that needs to be
evaluated is three corns Plus two
popcorns multiplied by a clock showing
five o'clock is equal to question mark
so what's the
answer pause the video if you'd like to
give these puzzles a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these
[Music]
puzzles let's solve the first
puzzle the first thing you need to do is
pay careful attention to each of the
equations we'll solve them step by step
let's focus on the first equation
there's cat plus cat plus cat is equal
to 30 this means 3 * cat is equal to 30
dividing both sides of the equation by
three gives that a single cat is equal
to
10 we will take this value and use it
for the next
equation this is cat plus head plus head
is is equal to 20 the value of cat is
equal to 10 then we need to add two
heads so this is 2 * heads is equal to
20 subtracting 10 from both sides gives
2 * heads is equal to 10 dividing both
sides of the equation by two gives that
a single head has the value of
five we'll take this value and use it
for the next
equation the next equation reads
head + 2 feet + 2 feet is equal to
9 the value of head is equal to 5 and
then we need to add a total of 4et and
this is equal to 9 subtracting five from
both sides of the equation gives 4 * a
single foot is equal to four and then
dividing both sides of the equation by
four gives that the value of a single
foot is equal to
one so we finally have the values we
need and we just need to evaluate this
last
expression the value of a head is equal
to 5 then the value of a foot is equal
to 1 and the value of a cat is equal to
10 so what's the value of five + 1 * 10
even this step causes a lot of Confusion
by the order of operations we need to
evaluate the multiplication first so 1 *
10 is equal to 10 and that means we have
5 + 10 giving us the solution to the
puzzle as 15 and that's the
answer now let's solve puzzle
two so we have a very similar system of
equations we're going to want to solve
it step by step so let's take a look at
the first equation we have corn plus
corn plus corn is equal to
75 this means 3 * corn is equal to 75
dividing both sides of the equation by
three gives the value of a single corn
is equal to
25 we will need this value for the next
equation the next equation reads corn
plus popcorn plus popcorn is equal to
65 the value of corn is equal to 25 then
we are going to add 2 times the value of
popcorn this will be equal to
65 subtract both sides of the equation
by 25 gives 2 * the value of popcorn is
equal to 40 dividing both sides of the
equation by two gives that the value of
popcorn is equal to
20 we take this value and we will apply
it into the next
equation so we have a clock that's
showing 2:00 plus popcorn plus corn is
equal to
47 so we have the value of 2:00 plus
popcorn is equal to 20 plus corn is
equal to 25 and this is equal to 47 20 +
25 is equal to 45 so we have the Clock
Plus 45 is equal to 47 subtracting 45
from both sides of the equation gives
the value of 2:00 is equal to
2 so we now have a final expression that
we need to
evaluate we have three corns plus two
popcorns times the value of the clock at
5:00 is equal to what so we'll start out
with the value of three corns 3 * 25 is
equal to
75 then we add the value of two popcorns
and that will be 2 * 20 which equals 40
we need to multiply this by the value of
the clock at
5:00 now the value of 2:00 is equal to
2 so if you were just taking a clock you
know that its monetary value doesn't
change depending on the time but being a
puzzle we are interested in the value of
the clock and it would seem to be
related to the time that it's showing so
if the clock is showing 5:00 what would
its value be well if 2:00 is equal to 2
it would make sense that 5:00 is equal
to 5 so let's go ahead and say that's
what the value is you could also say
it's two I wouldn't argue too much but I
think it's reason able in a puzzle that
you're supposed to pay attention to
these little
details so what is 75 + 40 * 5 equal to
once again we need to apply the order of
operations so the multiplication takes
precedence over the addition 40 * 5 is
equal to 200 so we have 75 + 200 and
that gives the answer of
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problem one video at a
[Music]
time